so this talk is about space lower bounds
for graph processing algorithms so why
do we care about such lower bounds and
such algorithms well this is because
graphs are a common abstraction for
representing real-world data and they're
used for processing modern networks such
as social networks web topologies
interaction graphs whatnot and one
common feature of modern graphs is that
there tend to be very large so very
often we cannot really fit these graphs
into the memory of our computers so
we're interested in designing graph
analysis primitives that use very
limited space and this is the setting
studied in the streaming model of
computation this is our model of
computation for this talk so for the
purposes of this talk our input is a
graph G there are n vertices and edges
in the streaming model of computation we
think of the vertices of the graph G is
known may be numbered 1 through n and
these are represented by the green dots
on the slide now the edges of the graph
G are presented to the algorithm in a
stream in an arbitrary order like this
really think of reading the edge set of
a graph of disk so as the algorithm is
reading the list of edge updates of the
graph it is limited in space usage it
cannot just store the entire graph and
solve the problem offline instead the
algorithm makes one or more passes over
the stream and has to output the answer
in the end of course we're mostly
interested in single pass algorithms we
want to just look at the data once use
very limited space and output the answer
well the problem of designing algorithms
for graph problems and the streaming
model of computation has received a lot
of attention we know how to solve many
graph problems in this manner for
example we know how to construct grafts
parsa fires or find large matchings and
graphs or approximate distances in
graphs in this way and many other
questions well a very common assumption
that we make is that well edges of the
graph do not fit into the memory of a
single compute node we usually assume
that at least the vertices of the graph
do so this is the reason why in the
graph streaming or semi streaming model
of computation the standard assumption
is that the algorithm can use n poly log
and space so n is the number of vertices
in the graph now this is very reasonable
for many problems that have been
considered and the streaming model of
computation space linear and the number
of vertices is definitely necessary and
sometimes this is for very clear reasons
it is often the case that just the sheer
size of the object that we're computing
is linear in the number of nodes think
of computing a large matching in the
graph or finding a sparse affair spanner
well there are other settings in which
the bound holds for less obvious reasons
for example if we want to determine
connectivity we still need to use at
least linear space even though the size
of the output is just one number well it
turns out however that this bound is not
universal it was sort of paper last year
we gave an algorithm for approximating
the size of maximum matching in a graph
given as a stream of edges in a random
order to a poly logarithmic factor well
using only poly logarithmic space and
the size of the graph this is
interesting and gives a solution with
space requirements exponentially smaller
than previously known in general this is
the best known algorithm own algorithm
for a graph problem that uses space sub
linear in the number of vertices of the
graph and let's suggest the following
question well can we find other graph
problems for which we can approximate
the cost of the solution perhaps without
computing the solution itself well using
space sub linear in the number of
vertices
well for our matching size results it
was crucial to assume that the order of
the edges was not worst case we're
assuming that the edges arrive in a
random order in the stream and in
general we're happy to make these
assumptions now if we want to be very
ambitious what we would like to shoot
for is an algorithm for solving other
graph problems or approximating solution
cost using space poly logarithmic and
the size of the graph and again if we
want to make the assumption that the
edges arrive at a uniformly at random
this is fine well this is the problem
that we consider and this work and the
problem that we look at as Max cut to
the question is suppose that we are
given the edge set of the graph as a
uniform as a randomly ordered stream is
it possible to get a good approximation
to the value of Max cut in this graph
using space Polly logarithmic and the
size of the graph ok so the talk is
mostly about max cap let me remind you
what max cut is and what we know about
it so the next step problem we are given
a graph such as the graph shown on the
picture and our task is to find a cut in
this graph that cuts as many edges as
possible here's one such example of a
cut who's just shown in red it cuts all
but two edges in the graph and is
optimal well what do we know about
approximating max cut for example
there's a trivial factor two
approximation to mascot value we know
that a uniformly random cut in the graph
cuts half the edges in expectation so
this is a trivial factor two
approximation we know how to do better
using the government's Williamson
algorithm or using spectral techniques
by trevisan and their combinatorial
implementations by Colin Sheshadri okay
so what does this imply for streaming
algorithms for max cut
well the trivial factor-2 approximation
achieved by simply looking at a random
cut yields immediately a trivial
algorithm that use the factor two
approximation in poly lock space for
that all we need to do is just count the
number of edges in the graph and output
that number / to the other extreme we
know that if if we're willing to spend
space linear and the number of vertices
in the graph then we can have an
arbitrarily good 1 plus epsilon
approximation at least information
theoretically so this is achieved by
simply storing a random sample of n over
epsilon squared edges of the graph so
the question that we ask in this work is
well is it possible to do better than
the trivial factor-2 approximation well
still using poly logarithmic space and
the size of the graph how do you know
where it is um right so I guess you can
write you can get this assumes that you
know the number of edges but you can
always guess two different notion son
now this wouldn't assume this wouldn't
even need the assumption that that is in
the random order just sample agencies
that's a good question okay so the
question that we want to ask is well is
there something more interesting at this
extreme of the spectrum so can we do
better than factor too well still using
poly logarithmic space okay and our main
result is that well unfortunately this
is not possible we show that any single
pass streaming algorithm that
approximates the value of machs gut to
factor slightly better than 22 minus
epsilon for any constant epsilon
necessarily use a space polynomial in
the size of the graph and particularly
skirt and space is required now
furthermore this bound holds even if the
edges of the graph are presented to the
algorithm in a uniform the random order
well so this result rules out the
possibility of achieving non-trivial
algorithms for approximating max cut
value in bali log space but as we will
see later the techniques that we use
suggest that sub linear space algorithms
and particular algorithms were roughly
poly an eruv and poly log and space
might be possible in some settings so
this is the main result we also show
that getting arbitrarily good 1 plus
epsilon approximations to max cap value
in adversarial II ordered stream streams
essentially requires linear space this
result was also independent and
concurrently achieved by a coconut
off-camera the rest of the taco will
focus on the main result namely beating
the trivial factor two approximation
requires at least square root and space
well and we establish the main result by
using and analyzing the following hard
distribution based on random order for
any graph so there will be two cases the
yes case and the note case in the yes
case the input graph will be a random
bipartite multigraph there will be very
few repeated edges with expected degree
roughly 1 over epsilon squared so recall
that epsilon is our precision parameter
we're trying to prove impossibility of
obtaining 2 minus epsilon approximations
to mask it now in the no case our input
will be a random non bipartite
essentially a random non vibrate or any
rough with the same degree average
degree now since in the yes case the max
the graph is bipartite the max cut value
is naturally all the edges of the graph
it's just m in the mill case will show
that or it's easier to see that the max
cut value is not much bigger than half
of the edges of the graph so the graph
that we will see in the note case is
very far from being by protect okay so
since there is a gap between max cap
value R and in the yes and no cases for
our end for distribution it is
sufficient to just concentrate on this
distribution and show that squared and
space at least is required to
distinguish between the two in the
streaming model
the boat separate equals um there will
be right so there will be sampled the
size of each set will be so each
verdicts will belong to one side of the
x partition with probability one-half
and to the other side with probability
own path so will be slight deviations
any other questions okay so this is the
hard input distribution and so it's
based on earlier shreya graphs so before
I define the distribution properly let
me remind you some of the basic
properties of different new graphs that
will need we call that a graph G there's
samples from the GNP distribution if
each edge each pair UV belongs to is an
edge and in the graph G independently
with probability P the graphs that we
will be interested in will be earlyish
renew graphs and below the connectivity
threshold so the value of P that we're
interested in is alpha over n where
alpha is a sufficiently small constant
so it is known that if alpha is
sufficiently small then such graphs with
overwhelming probability are unions of
very small trees the sizes of these
trees are no bigger than log in
again some number of those with luggage
will right yes if alpha is small enough
they don't happen so but that's why it's
not very high probability so with
probability 1 minus order alpha cubed
will won't see any of those okay good
and so now i can define the heart input
distribution so recall again that we're
trying to prove that square root and
space is required to get to minus
epsilon approximation to max cut so
epsilon is our precision parameter so
the hard input distribution will be
naturally partitioned into K phases
where K is about 1 over epsilon squared
so in each phase in the input stream on
the algorithm will be presented with a
independently sampled random bipartite
editor a new graph below the
connectivity threshold Cynthia's case
the input will look like this there are
K phases and in each each of the phases
and independent by prototype or any
graph arrives all these graphs share the
same by partition so in particular if we
put them together the result is a
bipartite graph now the no case is very
similar again in each of the phases a
random bipartite order for any graph
arrives except that they do not share
the bipartition the by partition is
resampled uniformly random in each of
the phases because of that we can see
that the max cut value is exactly all
the edges in the s case and it is not
much bigger than half of the number of
edges in the no keys and the streams
arrived in random order so the entire
there's a British apply to the entire
that's it that's a good question so we
will analyze the process as is and then
show that the ordering in which the
edges arrive is within a little o of 1
enter Federation distance from meeting
from the random order so if you look at
the graph that is finally generated the
order in which the edges arrive here is
uniform the random so basically think of
each each of the sub graphs is arrived
arriving in around
okay so this is our distribution on on n
puts and now we will need to analyze it
will use the following natural que parte
communication problem for that so there
are key parties corresponding to the
phases of the of the end up roughly 1
over the square one of epsilon squared
players each player so the Jade player
receives the Jade the Jade phase graph
as input as well as the message from the
previous player and given this
information construct his own message
and sends it to the next player well
naturally and finally the cave player
has to announce the answer was at the
yes kisser than okies now the connection
to streaming algorithms is of course
that any single path streaming algorithm
for distinguishing between these yes and
no cases immediately leads to a protocol
for this que parte communication problem
the first player simply runs the
streaming algorithm on on their input
then ships the state of the memory to
the next player and they proceed in this
fashion so let me define the sequence of
random variables or other two sequences
of random variables and that represent
the state of the streaming algorithm
after the after reading the J phase of
the of the ambit so SJ yes will be the
random variable that corresponds to the
state of the algorithm after reading the
J phase in the yes case and as J now is
the same random variable for the na keys
so what we know is that if we start with
a streaming algorithm that approximates
max cut to better than 2 minus epsilon
factor and the following is true well
the first elements of the of these two
sequences are the same because the
algorithm starts in the same state and
the yes in the no cases and on the other
hand these two sequences diverge in
total variation difference distance
after K steps what we want to show is
that if this is the case then the
streaming algorithm must use use a lot
of space at least square of that now if
we were to analyze this que parte
communication problem it is not
immediately clear how to do this the
first one will have to reason about
arbitrary ways of compressing graphs
which we would like to avoid and second
this is a que parte communication
problem we would like to
work with simpler to party
communications so instead of looking at
the problem directly what we do is
define a tu parte communication problem
and reduce it to approximating max cut
on this distribution the benefit of this
is that now we only have to reason about
compressing information about this
hidden by partition as opposed to the
graphs that we see industry now this
will be easier
so let me define the problem now the two
parte communication problem that we use
is the is something that we call the
boolean hidden partition problem and
this is a variant of the boolean hidden
matching problem defined by Gavin ski
camp occur in Ellis Ross and Duvall so
in this problem there are two parties
Allison Bob now Alice gets a binary
vector X of length n as n good and it's
good to think of this lecture as
encoding a bipartition of the verdict
set of our graph so the vertices of the
graph has shown here as the green dots
and each vertex is labeled by 0 or 1 0
means it goes on one side of the x
partition one on the other side Alice
receives the string X and it compresses
the string into a message m and sends
the message to Bob now Bob together with
the message because the following two
pieces of it the first Bob gets the
graph G on the verdict set on the vertex
I am as shown on the slide now each edge
of the graph g is further annotated with
a label label w
so here the labels shown as zeros and
ones the labels convey the following
information in the yes case the label on
each edge UV is nothing but the sum
modulo 2 of the two bits corresponding
to the endpoints xu + x-c so hence in
the yes case the labels convey for each
edge the information of whether or not
the edges crosses the x position held by
Alice now in the null case however right
so for example here you see that the
those edges that have zeros are do not
cross the x partition and they're shown
as orange now in the no hice case
however the labels are uniformly random
and have exactly nothing to do with the
by partition that that LLS halt
the following operation will be used
later so note that if Bob is getting a
graph G as in put together with labels W
on the edges what Bob can do is look at
each each edge in the graph and only
keep those edges that have ones written
on them in the yes case this will have
the effect of only keeping those edges
of the graph that cross the x partition
held by Alice in the no case will this
will amount to just subsampling the
graph uniform a trap ok so this is a
problem this problem is an extension of
the boolean hidden matching problem
defined by Gavin ski camp occur in addis
russ and devolve and then further
studied by ver banegi the difference is
that for their problem the graph g that
bob was receiving was a uniformly random
matching on a constant fraction of the
note and it is important for us that the
graph should be a you from a random
order for any graph because we're
dealing with a uniformly random edge
arises
Oh
so this is the boolean hidden matching
problem now in fact we will use a
natural distributional version of this
problem so something that we call d bhp
and this distribution version of the
problem Alice gets a uniformly random
string X so think of a uniformly random
by partition of the vertices of the
graph and Bob gets a graph sampled from
the GNP distribution this is a graph
below the connectivity threshold gmb now
we are in the yes case independently
with probability one-half and in the no
case otherwise what lower bond on em are
you going to prove on the message
underlies the messages squirt on Florida
I'm just gonna fin few so why can't
Alice just send a bunch of vertices that
are on the same side and then Bob will
see um the question is how many so for
example she can send the squirrel n
vertices all right the constant number
what you see if she said no she sends a
constant number of vertices then see
Bob's graph is a order for any graph
below the connectivity threshold so
think of really very small components
you need to you need to get let's say at
least one agent that set so square root
n vertices is exactly the fresh hold at
which this will work and this is the
bound
that's a great question so what's the
meaning of the last what do you mean by
s case independently with books um we
define a distribution on inputs so
inputs are defined you know first flip a
coin and with probability one-half as
the yes case with probability one-half
is the no keys that's the distribution
on inputs and the task is to distinguish
between between the two cases any other
questions
good okay so we show a reduction from
the distributional version of the
boolean hidden partition problem to
approximating max cut value so
specifically we show that any single
past streaming algorithm that
approximates max cut value to a factor
better than 2 to 2 minus epsilon say
with probability 99% yields a prodigal
for the distributional version for Alice
and Bob that allows them to achieve
advantage at least Omega epsilon squared
epsilon is our precision parameter over
random guessing whether or not it was
the ESR than a case now later will prove
that the any such protocol has to have
communication at least square root and
and this will give the result ok so this
is the task let's see how this works
we're given an algorithm for
approximating mascot value to factor it
better than better than 2 and we want to
design a prodigal for our 2 parte
communication problem now of course the
main issue is that the distribution on
our inputs naturally consists of K
phases and we want a protocol for a
two-body problem now it turns out
however that we can we can do this and
this is essentially by the hybrid
argument so again we call that we define
this set of two sequences of variables
s0 s1 s2 in the yes case and the same
set of sequence of variables for the
note keys well no so these variables
represent the state of the streaming
algorithm as after having read the jade
phase of the endless sequence so we know
that initially these two sequences start
out at the same being equal because the
algorithm starts in the same state and
they diverge and total variation
distance over the key steps of the
process now in particular what this
means is that there must be at least one
step J star to recall the informative
index where this divergence was not
trivial so the total variation distance
between the distribution of the state of
the algorithm of the yes case at step J
plus 1 should be at least Omega 1 over K
bigger than the total variation distance
at the previous and this is exactly the
index that we use
so given her input X which enclose the x
partition of the graph Alice will run
the streaming algorithm up to this
informative index and then ship the
content of the memory of the algorithm
to Bob now given that Bob will generate
a so recall that bob has a graph G and
with labels on the edges are given this
graph G but will simply keep those those
edges that have ones written on them in
the yes case this will nicely generate
the next stage of the input process and
the null case this will give a uniformly
random subsampling of his graph one can
see that from the distribution of of the
state of the algorithm at step g star
plus one one can distinguish between the
yes and the no cases with advantage at
least one of our key so this is a
reduction from from approximating max
add value to our problem now it remains
to show that solving the distribution of
boolean hidden partition problem
requires communication at least Ronan
and the in the two-party setting and I
won't get into the proof but let me just
show to say that the proof uses for
analytic techniques it is it follows the
steps of Gavin ski camp occur in a this
rouse and evolve and the difference that
we have to handle is that in their case
the graph that bob was receiving is
there was a uniformly random matching a
fixed size in our case this is a random
order for any graph but this can be
handled now let me skip the details of
this
okay so what we just saw is that is the
following I first defined a distribution
over inputs where any algorithm any
streaming single pass algorithm that
approximates max cut value to affect her
better than two requires at least square
root and space now the graph was just
through the result as advertised was a
result for a uniform the random ordering
of fetches one can show however that the
ordering of edges and the stream that we
defined is closed and total variation
distance to a uniformly random ordering
and this gives the final race
okay so this was a space lower bound for
the setting where the graph arrives in a
uniformly random order in fact a similar
impossibility result can be proven for a
related setting where the stream
contains not the edges of the graph in a
uniformly random order but rather and
pollywog an iid samples of the edges of
the end of graph one can also see that
this bound estate for our distribution
is essentially what we are showing is
that it is hard to distinguish between a
random reasonably sparse order trainee
bipartite graph and a non bipartite
graph without using square root n
denotes a square dance space one can see
that this bound is tied for this
distribution because one can sample
uniformly at random roughly squared and
vertices in the graph and maintain
random walks of logarithmic length out
of these vertices now in the case that
the graph is bipartite will maintain who
will maintain the walks of even and odd
length if the graph is bipartite that as
we're in the yes case the even and odd
random walks will not intersect in the
case when the graph is non bipartite the
walks will mix in log n steps and by the
birthday paradox we'll see some
intersections and we will be able to
distinguish between the two cases
okay so what this shows is that the
bound is tight only for our particular
distribution but a very interesting open
problem would be to see if a better than
factor of two approximation for max cap
value using similar techniques so let's
say poly log and length random walks in
the streaming model using roughly rule
and space could be obtained for the
general problem and of course the very
interesting problem is to obtain other
streaming algorithms for other graph
problems we're in space sub linear and
the number of vertices of the graph
this can list them some other parameters
that are they can separate this two
distributions like it clearly maximum
muck Scott is not only parameter that is
we're different for this two
distributions how I see like that's a
good question right so essentially what
to do the way I'm yeah it's a good
question I don't smell so this seems to
be saying something about the hardness
of doing long-range exploration in the
streaming model without using / space
right so the only way of distinguishing
YouTube between the two pieces is
basically by doing long random walks and
this seems to be saying something about
this but I'm not not sure if I have
better formulations or more general
properties that distinguishes it was the
same approach might give a space lower
bound for online distinction between a
forest and i grafted at least one cycle
you're choosing they're so good oh I
think so sparsely different cycles right
i see i see so you're saying that
distinct distinguishing between the case
when let's say these log in size trees
never had a unicycle component and
actually did have a unicycle component
right that's that seems interesting okay
so what is the odd girth this is surest
odd cycle yes I see so this I guess
that's the lower amount for that right